Hello!
Hello everybody!
Oh my god, I don't know why I'm so nervous.
Today I've just been like butterflies.
It's my birthday!
Yes, my real birthday.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's been... what a day.
What a fucking day.
Alright, so...
So, if you guys didn't notice, we have new alerts now.
A huge shoutout to the Dragoons for giving me some new alerts.
We finally updated our new alerts, guys!
So we have new alerts for members, gifted memberships, super chats, akasupas...
And streamlabs.
So all of those will be new alerts coming in.
And, oh my god, I...
Thank you guys!
Thank you all for all the birthday wishes, everybody!
I really, really, really do appreciate it, guys.
I wish I had more presents to give you guys.
But I did tell you guys.
I spent majority of the time in terms of like projects and planning.
It was mostly regarding my new skin suit.
So I know I haven't uploaded the wallpapers yet or the 3D models.
All that stuff.
Soon.
This week.
I promise you guys.
It was just a lot of things back to back to back to back.
So I wasn't able to upload all the stuff yet from the skin suit debut.
But I will promise you guys that by the end of this week, Dave will be back.
And I will be uploaded.
And those are my gifts to you guys.
I also do have special gifts for you guys though.
You see down there at the bottom left side.
At the bottom left side.
I do have some special gifts there.
It might not be as elaborate or like as big as previous birthdays.
But like I tried my best.
There might be...
Some of you guys are like...
Doki.
Usually when a Vtuber has a birthday or a special thing going on.
Usually they will release a song or something.
Not today.
But sooner than you think.
But also not as professional as you think it is.
That's all I can say.
That's all I can say about it.
So that's a belated birthday gift I guess.
That's a...
It's gonna be a belated birthday gift.
Because...
You'll see why.
You'll...
All I can say is that...
No I don't wanna spoil it.
Fuck.
Okay.
I won't...
Nevermind.
I won't spoil it though.
I'm not gonna...
I'm not gonna spoil it.
That's all I can say.
Soon.
Sooner than you think.
I feel like.
Yeah.
Sooner.
Sooner than you think.
Oh my god.
I'm...
I'm just...
I don't know.
It's been a wild morning.
It's...
It's been...
It's been a very wild morning.
I feel like everybody expected some...
Everybody guessed...
A lot of people guessed correctly on, you know, the first announcement.
For those who are not on...
Also thank you everybody for the super chats.
I really, really do appreciate it everybody.
Thank you guys.
Thank you for all the support.
Lord Kurose says thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Happy birthday Doki.
Take your time on all this stuff and just know we appreciate it so much.
Thank you.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
I really, really, really do appreciate it guys.
Okay.
So like for those who are not on Twitter.
Yes, everybody.
Okay.
You know how like...
It's so hard to keep this a secret.
Anyway.
So, you know how I tweeted.
I was like, guys, 8 a.m.
And then people were like, what times?
I can't believe some of you guys were like, what time zone?
You guys...
I only work with one time zone.
I practically exist in PST.
That is my go-to time zone.
I say so much about West Coast, Best Coast.
But it was so funny.
People were like, which time zone?
I'm like, what do you mean which time?
You guys know my default is PST, you guys.
Like...
That is my default.
Al so.
Dark Thank you for the Thank you.
Thank you.
Happy birthday.
Thank you for the I really appreciate.
Thank you so much.
Um...
I saw Thank you.
Thank you.
Happy birthday Dokie.
Thank you for the Thank you.
Thank you.
And I feel young.
Thank you for the Thank you.
Thank you.
Speaking of good things coming our way, I do have several announcements, but I have to stall a little bit because...
There are like multiple announcements that I have to make today.
Multiple, uh, really?
Uh...
Oh my gosh.
I know you guys were like, there's more announcements?
Yeah!
I have to stall a little bit.
I don't know when I can make the...
Um...
I'm supposed to make this announcement too, but like...
Uh...
Well, several announcements.
There's already two that's confirmed already that I can make.
But I won't make all the announcements at once.
So I'm stalling until, like, I get confirmation on the final announcement.
Also, daddy, thank you for the 50 gifted chips!
Thank you, thank you!
I fucking...
Okay, not gonna lie.
I fucking love the alert at the bottom left.
Like...
So, um...
Like, even without the music, I can hear it playing.
And I can hear...
I can hear the song in my mind.
But...
Okay, oh my god.
I could, like, hear the music.
Oh my god.
Anyway, but the announcements are unrelated to the gift box over there.
So, like, you see that gift box?
That gift box down there is unrelated to the announcements.
Those are, like, future announcements.
Those are more, like, gift announcements.
Anyway.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, so, like, you know how, like, yeah, early in the morning...
Um...
Uh...
I saw a lot of people that were, like...
Like, 8am?
Can you even wake up at 8am?
True!
That...
I mean, like, that's a...
Cause even you were, like...
Yogi, why would you pick 8am?
Uh...
For whatever secret announcement that is.
And I'm, like...
You think I would pick 8am?
Do you really...
I...
You think I would willingly pick...
8am?
Like, no.
Basically...
It was basically...
The reason why it was 8am is because Anime Expo opens at 8am.
And, like, all this stuff there...
It was gonna be shown there anyway.
So they had to announce it before Anime Expo opens.
So, um...
The funny thing is that, uh...
Um...
So, like, the Haya announcement...
A lot of people guessed it correctly.
Cause they were, like, of course it's gonna be the Haya announcement.
Cause we already talked about it before.
Okay.
And, uh...
The thing is...
Sorry, I need to open the door.
Cause it's, like...
I talk so much that there's so much hot air blowing in.
That, like, it's so humid.
It's so...
I...
I'm, like...
I can't breathe.
It's so hot in here.
Um...
But...
Anyway.
Um...
So...
I suffered a lot with you guys.
With waking up at 8am.
To be fair, I wake...
I actually woke up at 7 in the morning.
Because...
Like, you know...
When you're so...
Excited.
Uh...
When you're so excited.
And you couldn't sleep.
Um...
So I got, like...
3 to 4 hours of sleep last night.
Because I was just...
Way too excited.
Because...
Nobody expected...
The nendoroid.
Yes!
I am gonna be a nendoroid!
Oh my god.
No one...
Okay.
Some people were like...
Oh my god.
What if?
But, like...
I don't think in your heart...
You expected a nendoroid announcement.
I am also, like...
In...
You know...
It's...
It's so hard to believe sometimes that...
It's so hard to believe!
I'm gonna be...
I'm gonna be a nendoroid!
Um...
But yes!
Coming soon!
Oh my gosh.
I...
I don't want...
I can't spoil...
What the accessories...
Are gonna be.
But...
Um...
You guys are gonna...
Love...
You guys are gonna love what I picked for the accessories.
And...
Okay.
This is a really funny story.
Uh...
Okay.
So, not a story.
But, like...
Um...
So, I had...
I looked at the sheet.
So, like...
When they propose...
The nendoroid stuff.
And they propose, like...
The expressions...
And the accessories.
It was so funny.
Because I was reading the...
I was reading the sheet.
And then...
In the notes...
It was like...
Make sure the mouth is slanted.
And like...
For like...
All the faceplates...
The notes were like...
Make sure the...
The smile is curved and slanted.
It is not regular face...
Not regular smile.
It has to be slanted.
I thought I was...
I was...
Like...
It was like...
Like a bolded note on the faceplates and everything.
And...
Um...
It was like...
It was...
Honestly...
Um...
Oh my gosh.
I'm just...
Out of words.
Because...
Uh...
It...
I'm not gonna cry.
But I just wanna say...
Um...
Thank you guys so much, Dragoons.
I don't think without you guys...
I could even...
The fact that, like...
I'm an indie VTuber.
And not a lot of indie VTubers...
Get a chance to...
Have a nendoroid.
Uh...
Because usually...
When you think of nendoroids...
It would go to, like...
Corporate.
You know?
So...
Like...
The fact that...
I was able to be...
Like...
Within...
Like, you know...
The rare indies that have the opportunity...
To...
To be a nendoroid...
It is...
Absolutely insane.
And...
Um...
Basically...
They work so...
Fast.
It...
Um...
Like...
It was...
They work so...
Cause like...
It's not like...
This deal...
Has been negotiated...
For like...
A long time...
It was like...
I don't wanna give...
I can't give details...
But it was like...
Much faster than I expected...
Because...
Um...
This was actually arranged by...
Uh...
This was arranged by...
My...
My agent...
And...
Uh...
My new staff team...
Um...
So...
My agent and my new staff team...
Worked on the...
On...
Getting me the nendoroid...
Um...
And...
Like...
I remember they were like...
Uh...
They emailed them and be like...
Hey...
Do you want to...
Uh...
You know...
Doki really...
Really wants...
Uh...
To...
Be a nendoroid...
And like...
She loves your stuff...
Like...
Are you open to this idea?
Of making...
Adding Doki Bear to the indie line...
Like...
For...
Uh...
Vtuber...
Vtuber indies with nendoroid...
And they were like...
Yeah!
Like...
Of course!
They were like...
Yeah!
We really want to work with her!
And...
Um...
It...
Oh my god!
Uh...
It's just...
Really hard to...
I can't believe they said...
Yeah!
I can't believe they said yes!
And...
At that time...
Um...
The original idea...
Was...
To do...
Um...
Was to do...
My new skin suit...
Um...
Because at that time...
Like...
Everything was...
Practically...
Like...
Done!
For my new skin suit...
And...
But then they were like...
They decided...
We decided...
Like...
All of us decided...
We talked about it...
And we decided to go with...
The...
Old skin suit...
Um...
Because...
Uh...
Because like...
We thought that like...
You know...
It would...
Like...
Retro...
Retro Doki...
Was a big part of my life...
And...
Um...
And then...
That gives me opportunities...
To maybe in the future...
If the cells go really...
Guys...
Hint hint...
If...
If the cells go...
Really really well...
For Retro Doki...
We might be able to get...
You know...
Hint hint...
Another Nendoroid...
Um...
You know...
Current...
Current skin suit Doki...
Um...
I don't know...
Hint...
So...
You know...
I have more than...
Just...
Uh...
More than just like...
Um...
One version of me...
As a Nendoroid...
And...
So...
Yeah...
So that's why...
We decided to go with...
Uh...
Retro Doki...
Um...
And...
Oh my gosh...
Like...
It's just...
I...
Like...
When they were like...
They were like...
We're gonna announce it at Anime Expo...
And I was like...
That soon?
That's...
I...
I legitimately...
Expected it to be...
Announced like...
End of the year...
I did not think it would be like...
They're like...
By the way...
We're gonna like...
If everything's good to go...
Uh...
We're gonna like...
Let people know...
Anime Expo...
And I was like...
I was like...
What?
Oh...
I'm still like...
I'm still living through the rush of...
The fact that I'm a nendoy...
Like...
Oh...
Oh my god.
It's just...
I was not ready.
I was honestly...
I was not ready at all...
Um...
Uh...
But...
It's...
Ugh...
It was wild...
And then...
I told this story at Anime Expo...
I was at Expo during my panel and basically they told me that the Nendoroid was going to be announced at 8am.
So, you know, Hyatt announced the thing at 8am as well.
And so like, I was like, oh sweet, like the double whammy.
And then so like, 8am passed and then I was like, where's Nendoroid?
And then everybody, you know, expected the Hyatt thing to be like the last announcement that was going to happen.
Because I was like, 8am and like the Hyatt PC collab was like the only thing that came out at 8am.
So then I asked my staff and I was like, Also Lita, thank you for the Aka- Aka-Supa!
Thank you, thank you!
Happy birthday Doki!
I'm so happy to see you become such a successful Vtuber!
I hope we can have you for many, many more years.
Thank you, thank you for the Aka-Aka-Supa!
That really, really means a lot.
But basically, so...
I'm a god.
So I messaged my staff.
I messaged my staff and I was like, Oh, um, staff, where... where...
Where's the Nendoroid announcement?
Where... where is it?
And then my staff that's at Anime Expo was like, Oh, don't worry.
Um, they said it'll be 8.08.
Your tweet is scheduled for 8.08.
And I was like, 8.08?
Okay.
Okay, 8.08.
And then 8.08...
I was like refreshing the, like, the Good Smile Company Twitter accounts.
I was like refreshing over and over and over again.
Because I was like, where... where...
I need to... I want to... I need to see it!
Like, I need to see it to believe it!
So...
So, 8.08 passed.
And then 8.08 was Iron Mouse's paw figure.
I was like, this is not me.
This is Bishoucho!
I was just like, wait a minute!
Did they think I'm Iron Mouse?
This isn't me!
Iron Mouse is 8.08!
And then I was like, messaged my staff again.
I was like, wha... what?
Where's...
Where's Nendoroid?
I was like, wait...
8.08 was Bishoucho!
And then my staff must reply back.
I was like, oh sorry.
There's like two to three more Bishoucho announcement.
And then it's your turn.
And I was like, okay.
Oh my god.
So, I was like, what?
I was waiting in anticipation because I didn't know the exact time.
I didn't know the...
I didn't know the exact time of like when it was going to show up.
I just kept refreshing and refreshing and refreshing.
And like getting baited.
By other announcements.
Until like I showed up and I was like, it's there.
It's finally there.
It's real!
Oh my god!
Um...
Oh my god.
I was so...
It was so hard to be patient, you know?
And then...
I had no words.
I honestly...
I have no words.
I was just... I'm there!
And Android is real!
The one thing we're missing now is the Funko Pop.
When we get the Funko Pop, then we've truly made it.
The Triforce.
We have the U2's figure.
We have the Nendoroid.
All we're missing right now is the Funko Pop.
To complete the triangle.
Um...
Hey guys, there were...
There were so many announcements.
So you guys didn't know.
Um...
During the...
Well, I mean, you guys should know because I talked about it during the Skinsuit reveal.
But...
At Anime Expo...
And at the...
Um...
Oh my gosh, sorry.
It's so hard to talk.
I'm just so...
I'm just so happy.
I'm just really happy right now.
So it's so hard to verbalize my thoughts.
It's so hard to communicate right now.
Um...
And you know, I'm usually really good at yapping.
But like today, I'm just...
My mind is like...
All frazzled.
And um...
Yeah, like...
It's just...
It's so hard to like...
Word anything in my head today.
Because there's just...
There's so many things going on.
And I told you guys to like...
July...
July is crazy.
July is actually crazy.
Thank you everybody.
Thank you guys so much.
For all the birthday wishes.
I really appreciate it.
Um...
I just...
I never expected to get an Android.
That's really good.
It was honestly like...
A dream of mine.
To get an Android.
I was a Nendoroid collector.
Well, not recently.
I was a lot younger.
I used to collect a lot of Nendoroids.
Growing up.
And you know...
It's just so surreal.
To like...
See me as a Nendoroid.
And then like...
Oh my gosh.
I'm just like thinking like...
Am I gonna go to a random anime store?
And then I'm gonna see me?
Like...
Like I'm just thinking like...
Oh my god.
Will I like...
Go to some random anime store?
And then I'd be like...
There's me!
It's actually...
It's like... you know...
Real life sighting.
Like you know... Everything for me is just virtual.
But to like see a wild Doki IRL...
It's just...
It's gonna be so weird.
It's gonna be so fucking weird.
Um...
So...
It is honestly just...
I'm just... I'm so frazzled.
I'm so fucking frazzled right now.
Thank you all for the happy birthday wishes guys.
Thank you all for the birthday wishes.
And all the super chats and the members.
And everything.
I really...
Really appreciate it.
Um...
I'm trying not to cry.
I'm trying...
I'm trying not to cry because...
You know...
I'm usually not used to having...
So many things happening on my birthday.
Unlike my real birthday.
So...
So it's been pretty...
Overwhelming.
And um...
Ah!
Okay.
I have to actually move on to the next subject.
Or I'm gonna actually like...
Fucking cry or something.
Oh my god.
Um...
It's just crazy.
To say as an indie.
To have an android as an indie.
It's just like...
It's really rare for indies to get an opportunity like this.
So...
I'm really thankful to my team.
And to my agent.
To one of my...
One of my three...
My two agents.
For helping me...
Accomplish this.
And reaching out to Good Smile Company.
Asking if they were interested.
And then people at the Good Smile Company be like...
Yeah!
Let's do it!
And I was like... Really?
You're not fucking with me right?
Like...
Ha ha ha ha!
Oh...
So...
I'm just really happy.
You guys are gonna love the accessories.
That I picked.
Um...
For an android.
You guys are gonna love it.
Um...
Alright.
Moving on.
Moving on to the next...
Subject that I should be talking about.
By the way, like I said, um...
The announcements will be at a later time.
Um...
Because...
The announcement and what's in the gift will be at a later time.
Um...
Because I need to get a final confirmation on one of the final announcements.
So...
Right now I'm just talking about all the current announcements that we've had.
Um...
Anyway.
The other thing is...
Yes!
It is up!
The fourth!
Pre-order!
Uh...
Yes!
Okay.
If one of my...
Sorry.
I know like...
Right now there's only one mod at the moment in chat.
So if my one mod can...
Can post a link to...
To the...
Hyatt pre-order for me.
And then I'll ping it... I'll pin it right now.
Um...
But... Yes!
We have...
The Hyatt iBipad.
The power!
PC case collab!
With wall scroll!
Keycaps!
Desk mat!
If you order the limited edition...
I said limited edition?
If you order... Oh yeah it is.
If you order...
If you order the limited edition...
You'll get like bonus stuff.
So like the bonus things are like...
Stickers...
It's like...
Stickers, cards...
And uh...
I'm trying to remember everything that was in the bonus collection.
A charm... There's a lot of stuff.
There's so many things!
Oh my god there's...
There's a lot... There's a lot...
There's a lot of stuff.
But I really want you guys to know...
That uh...
For the...
I worked really hard...
With Hyatt and...
iBipower...
To make it super...
Personalized...
In a way that I think you Dragoons are gonna love.
I mean will love because like...
You can literally see what's like in it.
Um...
And...
I'm a keycap collector.
I collect keycaps.
I um...
I was very...
Very...
Very picky when it came to the keycaps.
Um...
Oh shit I'm sorry I dropped my cough drops.
I was very...
Very like picky and...
Uh...
Stingy on like what the...
Keycaps were supposed to look like.
Um...
Because like I said like...
I was very particular about it.
And like I...
As someone that loves...
What's the word called?
What's the word?
Uh... Fuck.
The like symbols on keycaps...
Oh no.
Guys sorry I'm...
My brain's not working today guys.
My brain's not working today.
Um...
But the...
God what was that word called?
The symbols on the keycaps.
Not the regular ones.
The...
What's the keycap?
Keycap words.
Keycap terminologies.
You know like the...
The pretty...
Icons.
The novelties.
Yes!
I'm sorry my brain's not working today.
I'm really overwhelmed everybody.
I'm super overwhelmed today.
But the novelties.
Um...
So...
The novelties...
For the keycaps.
I was very very particular on...
What... How it was supposed to look like.
I don't know if I could show the first draft.
But like maybe in the future.
I'll have to ask...
I'll have to ask the people at...
I Buy Power and Hyatt.
Whether or not I can show the very first draft of the keycaps.
Or not.
But I requested...
Very particular novelties.
Um...
For this collection.
And I had a huge hand in designing...
A lot of these.
In terms of my vision.
And you guys can see there's a lot of dragoons and everything.
I wanted to include my dragoons and dad.
Um...
I wanted to include as many merch as I can.
Because like you know...
Without my dragoons I can't do the things that I can do.
Like I wouldn't be able to achieve the things...
Um...
That I've achieved without your support.
So like I want you guys to be with me on this journey.
And like be with me on my merch and everything.
Like it's not just like a me effort.
It's like a team effort.
Guys remember we are a team.
So any like mistake that I do it is a team.
Hahahaha.
So any mistake that I do...
We did together.
Hahahaha.
You can't just be in the positives of the team.
Okay?
We are there for the negatives as well.
Hahahaha.
Like this is the positive part.
But like you guys have to be there.
When we fuck up too.
Hahahaha.
The shared liability.
Anyway.
Um...
I'm gonna show you guys the keycaps.
Cause like if you guys didn't see the keycaps.
There's like stuff I wanted to show you guys.
From the keycaps.
So these are the keycaps.
And I want you guys to see down here.
Uh...
You can see that croaky is...
Okay wait let me...
Oh so by the way I said I wanted the tomato.
For this right here.
Okay oh my gosh you're just like...
Hahahaha.
And you guys can see the tomato right here.
I...
The tomato was not originally in...
Uh...
Was not originally in it.
But like I requested to have like tomato.
Cause I wanted the keycaps to be like...
Everything that I've represented.
Like everything that you dragoons have done.
Everything that I have done in my career.
And uh...
In my very short career of like six months.
But like this basically...
The keycaps is basically like...
A piece of history.
Um streaming.
And so...
And then we have a tomato goon too.
Right here.
We have a tomato goon as well.
Uh right here.
I requested that too.
I was like I need the tomato goon.
And then obviously I requested to have...
Uh the dragoons.
And the keycaps as well.
And okay but I need you guys to look at a particular...
Um...
A particular...
Uh...
Um...
Keycap design.
Also I love this.
This one they added in.
And I was like this is beautiful.
But I need you guys to see this.
Uh...
Okay.
So...
Um...
Croaky is in the...
Uh...
Keycap collection.
And I need you guys to know...
That Croaky...
Was such a last minute...
Addition.
It was literally...
Okay.
It was literally added...
So last minute.
Um...
To the point where...
Cause after I did the croaky stream...
I was like croaky has to be in the keycap collection.
Like croaky has to be in it.
And it was so...
So last minute.
That because we added croaky in...
Is the reason why we don't have...
The samples at anime.
Because...
Because they were like it's too late.
We can't get the samples in time.
By adding croaky we can't get it in time.
For the convention.
So...
So that's why...
That's why there's no keycaps like shown.
Like physical keycaps shown.
Um...
At the booth at high end.
Because I demanded for croaky...
To be added.
To be added in.
And um...
Like basically...
Like uh...
We were gonna add one...
I was like oh I sent screenshots of like croaky...
Uh pictures.
Like to potentially be made into...
Keycaps.
And uh...
And then I was like you know you can pick any one of them.
And then the staff...
At high end slash ibuypower...
Loved the croaky so much.
They were like...
Let's add all four.
They were like fuck it.
Let's add more keycaps in there.
We're gonna add all four croaky's into the collection.
Because they were just gonna...
We were just gonna...
It was just one.
We were gonna just add one.
But they were like no.
Let's just add all four of them.
So...
I'm really happy that uh...
I'm really happy croaky made it in.
Because yeah it was...
Incredibly last minute.
I am just as shocked as all of you guys.
That croaky managed to make it in.
Like all four of...
Everybody's like one or two.
But croaky gets like four.
I was like wow.
Wow how come your mom lets you have four croaky's.
I don't...
How come...
How come they let you have four croaky's.
Also my oshimark is there too.
Um...
But yeah that's...
It just looks amazing.
The collection really does look so amazing.
Like look at...
Look at the packaging.
Like what the...
Oh my god.
I love the packaging too.
Like the illustrations.
I wanna keep the box.
The box looks amazing.
And um...
What else?
And then there's like the keycaps too.
This is the keycap box.
So it's more themed towards the dragoons.
Cause like I'm on the...
I'm on the PC box.
But you guys get to be on the keycaps box.
So like all the dragoons over here.
Um and also the packaging for that.
And oh yeah the wall scroll.
Oh my gosh.
The wall scroll.
Look at that beautiful artwork.
I wish I could show you guys the drafts.
It was so difficult to pick.
Um...
The artwork for...
The artwork for this.
Because like...
There was like three other poses.
And the reason why I picked this particular pose.
Was because of the dragoons.
Because I loved how the dragoons were positioned.
Because I was like...
Oh my god the dragoons look amazing.
I love how the dragoons look amazing.
And this one.
I don't care what I...
I don't care about my poses.
But the dragoons look so good.
And that's...
That's why I picked this one particularly.
I just loved how all the dragoons were positioned in the artwork.
So um...
That's why I picked this particular pose.
And this particular like arrangement.
Um...
That's us.
And then there's the desk mat too.
So uh...
If you guys never had a doki desk mat.
Now is the time to finally own...
A doki desk mat.
It is...
Oh my gosh.
It's still...
It's really surreal to have like a...
Gaming gear collection in general.
Because um...
It's...
As a gamer it's...
It's not something that...
I guess like I think I would have.
I'm sorry.
Oh my gosh.
Sorry that was like...
It's just like...
It's just hard to believe like...
That this is possible.
And especially keycaps.
And...
Um...
Like a PC case and everything.
Like I remember in the past...
I would tell you guys like...
Guys I don't think I'm gonna get a PC case.
Like...
And um...
I remember you guys would be like...
Doki you're gonna get a PC case in the future.
You're gonna get it.
And I was like guys I don't know.
I don't know guys.
And then it's also like one of the reasons why...
I never upgrade...
Like before Rest in Peace PC-kun.
But it's also why...
PC-kun lived as long...
As he did.
Because like I put out hope...
That um...
I would one day earn a...
Um a PC collab.
Even though PC-kun was dying...
Was like you know...
It was dying for a while.
Even before...
Six months ago.
It was dying for a while.
And PC-kun lived um...
Way too long for like...
How little life it has left.
Um because I've always hoped...
Like maybe...
Maybe I'll get a...
PC collab one day.
And cause I was like what if I upgrade?
And then I get like...
A message being like...
I got a PC collab for you.
And then you know I was always like...
I was so paranoid.
Cause I was like what if...
What if I upgrade and then I get that message.
Like that would be such a waste of money.
So...
Um...
I held hope.
And it finally...
It finally happened.
And...
Oh my god.
It...
It finally happened.
I'm so happy cause it really does look...
Um...
It really looks amazing.
And I cannot wait to see...
Uh...
So many dragoons.
Um...
All the dragoons.
Not all of them.
Cause I know it's very expensive.
But for those who are able to pre-order it.
Uh...
To be able to you know...
Like show photos of the builds that you do.
Or like just show photos of...
Your keycaps and uh...
And like the desk mat.
And everything.
And like I said thank you so much to...
Hiit and uh...
iBuyPower with working with me on this.
Um...
Especially as an indie.
It's really...
It's just really weird.
To be able to...
Get all of this as an indie.
Because you know...
Um...
I'm like...
Cause you don't really expect...
A lot as an indie.
Because you don't have like...
I guess like... corporate backing.
So to be able to accomplish...
And be able to receive...
Um...
All these offers from companies.
Like companies reaching out to us.
Or we like reaching out to companies and asking if they...
Are willing to like you know...
Collab or sponsor.
Um...
It's so surreal.
It's so... It's hard to believe sometimes.
It really is hard to believe.
Um...
And that's why I have a million things going on.
Because...
It's like... I'm like thinking like...
Oh no like...
By next year...
Will I still have the similar opportunities again?
By next year?
Or...
I just want...
I guess like... What's the word?
I wanna...
Take the chances as I...
As I get them.
Because I don't know when...
Um... When these like...
Chances are gonna stop coming.
So I'm trying... I'm trying...
That's why I say yes to a lot of things.
Because like I want to take advantage...
Of the fact that you know...
I'm able to do all of this...
Now?
Um...
Now and not the...
Like I... So that like you know...
I'll be like being able to experience these opportunities.
Uh... And...
Just being able to do all these amazing...
Uh... Things!
Because of you guys!
Uh...
So yeah!
Um... I'm so happy.
I'm really really...
Really happy.
Um...
That all of these are coming in.
And... Oh my gosh!
Okay I need to show you... I... I yoinked this from Twitter.
Whoever took this photo...
Thank you.
I yoinked this off of Twitter from you.
But this is basically what...
What the...
Display looked like.
It had a little... Like a birthday set up.
At the Hyatt slash...
Um... iBuyPower booth.
At Anime Expo.
And like this is what it looks like.
Um... So yeah!
They even got a cake and everything!
They got a cake and like there's like streamers...
And balloons.
And you guys can see everything...
But the keycaps because of CROQI.
Uh...
Um...
Everything's here!
Excluding the keycaps but everything's here!
Hahaha!
You too!
Can get a triangular PC just like me!
Um...
And fit it in the square hole!
Uh... Nexi thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you!
Happy birthday Doki!
I'm so happy for you and everything you've accomplished.
Uh... You've come so far and I can't wait to see what comes next.
We're all proud of you by the way.
Uh...
Base Iran ship.
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you!
Oh okay so...
Alright...
Um... This is a FOMO story.
But like...
I now have a new FOMO story.
So if you're at a...
I will never tell this on stream.
So...
It will die with me on stream.
But...
If...
If you're at a convention...
Um...
And you want more FOMO stories...
I have a new one now.
I have a new...
I have a new one.
I have two...
Guys I did it!
Now I have two FOMO stories!
Let's go!
Andrew thank you for the 50 gifted ships!
Thank you!
I really appreciate it!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Um... Why do you hate us?
Okay...
Because some of you guys were like...
But Doki... You haven't announced any conventions!
In Asia!
Great segue!
How am I supposed to...
How am I supposed to like...
Get those FOMO stories...
When all your conventions are in Europe...
And in Australia!
Good question!
Good question over there!
Nice segue!
YouTuber fan number 13...
Um...
I will make my first announcement!
I'm still gonna stall for the other announcements...
But like...
Um... I think I can make my first announcement...
Because this one was like...
This one has been confirmed that I can announce it!
You guys might have already saw the hints for it already!
Um...
But...
I will be at Malaysia!
Yeah!
That's me!
I...
Will be in...
Malaysia!
For any...
I'm so sorry if I'm pronouncing it wrong...
Sorry I said right but that's not it...
I can't even... I can't even word that correctly...
But...
I will be at this convention...
On August 23rd to 25th...
Oh my gosh...
There will be actual...
There will be merch sold there...
As well!
So I'm actually super excited...
Um... I saw previews of the...
Um... Of the merch that will be sold...
At this convention...
In Malaysia...
So... Oh my gosh I'm so excited for you guys to see it...
But yes!
Finally!
I can announce some of my...
Asia conventions!
Um...
We were missing Asia...
Because we already went to Europe...
We already went to Australia...
Canada and the United States...
I'm very sorry South America...
But you really...
But like...
I don't know who to approach regarding...
South America conventions...
And we haven't had any South American conventions approach us...
I'm very sorry...
Latin America bros...
Um...
But...
Um... We have another convention...
To announce for...
The Doki World Tour!
Yeah!
Um...
We are losing...
Hahaha...
I can't come to Brazil...
If nobody requests me to come to Brazil...
Hahaha...
How do I go to Brazil...
If I'm not getting requested...
Um...
Hahaha...
Anyway...
This is one of the many announcements...
That I'm going to be making today...
Because we had a really great segue into this...
Um...
Regarding FOMO Stories...
And...
I'm really really excited to...
Um...
Go to Animagaki...
I'm so sorry if I'm pronouncing it wrong...
You know my pronunciation is not great...
Hahaha...
Am I pronouncing it correct?
I don't know...
I'm sorry...
Um...
Oh my gosh...
Also...
This other one that was confirmed to me...
That I can announce about it...
Uh...
Is that...
I can't fully announce what it is...
But...
I'm going to announce...
Dragon's in Korea!
Hahaha...
Uh...
There is...
Maybe something happening in Korea...
Soon as well...
Hahaha...
So...
There will be a special event...
In Korea as well...
So...
That's another thing to...
Uh...
To look forward to...
Can't really announce more details about it...
Because...
That's the only thing I can say...
That's literally the only thing I can say...
About that event...
I have no graphics for it...
Told you!
When I say World Tour...
I mean it!
I mean World Tour...
Guys...
I did say...
If I mean World Tour...
It is going to be a World Tour...
I want to be involved in as many places...
As possible...
I want to come to as many...
As many places as I can...
To meet all the dragoons from around the world...
Um...
Because...
Uh...
Because like...
You know...
I never really had that chance in the past...
It was very rare for me to be able to...
Talk to my dragoons personally...
And like...
Just like...
More personalized talks with dragoons...
And being able to see that you guys are real...
And like you are not like...
You are not like chatbots...
Hahahaha...
I am like...
Oh my god...
They are not fucking bots...
They are not AI...
Like my mom didn't buy...
A thousand AI bots...
To talk to me...
But in my chat...
They are real people...
They are actually real...
Hahahaha...
Um...
That's why...
Okay...
Truth be told...
I don't know if this is similar to other Vtubers...
But like...
I personally think that like...
Conventions...
I don't really...
In terms of like...
I don't really go overtime as well...
At conventions...
You know...
I would have like...
Like a set time...
That I am supposed to end it off...
But I tend to go overtime...
And I tend to stay much longer...
Than like what is...
You know...
What was agreed upon...
Like officially...
Because you know...
I really enjoy meeting my dragoons...
And I really enjoy talking to them...
And meeting them...
And everything...
And...
I would say that like...
I personally think...
In general...
I definitely make more money...
If I just stream...
Versus like doing conventions...
In terms of like...
Superchat Avenue and stuff like that...
Or taking other...
Maybe if I have a sponsored stream at that time...
Or anything...
But... I don't care about that...
I don't care about that...
I...
Even then...
We've actually negotiated with conventions...
They're like...
The appearance fee might be too high for them...
Depending on like...
Exchange rate...
And stuff like that...
Because my appearance fee is based off of...
US dollars...
And...
Because of that...
Some places might not be able to...
Afford like...
The exchange rate...
Being fucked with every other country...
But the US dollar...
Fucking US...
I feel like...
Every country but US...
Has had like...
The currency exchange rate...
Is not doing great...
But...
Unless you're from US...
I've had moments...
Where...
USA...
Other than...
No!
You have to see the exchange rate...
Of Euros...
Versus US dollars...
Because like...
The Euro is falling now...
The Euro...
The Euro is like...
Falling too...
Because I was sending money...
Over...
Because...
My friends...
One of my like...
Friends...
Was like...
Hey I bought you something...
But like...
You gotta pay me back...
So I can ship it...
And I was like...
Wait...
It's not expensive...
I was so surprised...
Because it used to be more expensive...
So I was like... Oh my god...
It's happening...
I was like...
The Euro is finally falling...
Not the Euro 2...
Oh my god...
I'm truly in the...
This is why I always ask for...
US dollars...
I'm truly in the...
Anyway...
Wait...
That's not good...
Okay...
Anyway...
As I was saying...
Fuck...
I have a convention...
I don't think...
The exchange rate is really high...
For this type of fee...
I told my staff team...
That I'm very open to negotiate...
Regarding appearance fees...
Just because...
Like I said...
Honestly...
My top priority is...
Meeting my dragoons...
From around the world...
So I'm doing meet and greets...
And doing panels...
All sorts of things...
At the convention...
I don't make much...
I put a lot more investment...
Into...
Even despite...
If we agreed upon this...
I tend to go...
Over time...
Just because...
I feel like...
I just want you guys to have a great experience...
It's very rare to be able to have this opportunity...
Especially like...
Meet and greets...
Because in meet and greets...
It's like...
It's very hard stop...
You guys fight for it...
You guys...
You guys fight for those slots...
So that's why...
I remember in like...
I went like...
An hour plus over time...
Because there was like...
It was like...
It was just lined up...
It was not paid or anything...
There was still a lot of dragoons there...
And then I was like...
Are you okay with going overtime?
I was like...
Yeah...
I remember it was day 2...
And then my staff member...
Was like...
You went overtime...
On day 1...
But we don't want your voice...
We don't want you to burn out...
Because at that time...
My voice was starting to die a little...
So my staff member was like...
We got a cap for the second day...
My staff member was like...
Okay we got a cap for Doki...
Because she can't do that twice...
Because we don't want...
She has like...
She has dokami...
It was also because I had dokami...
Right after that too...
So...
So they were like...
We can't do overtime for day 2 Doki...
We are sorry...
You have to sleep early...
So you can make it to dokami as well...
So I'm sorry that we had to cut the line...
On day 2...
But it was great...
I'm just really happy to be able to do all these conventions...
And...
I can't wait to do many many...
Many many many many many more...
I want to...
For you guys...
Alright so...
I have other stuff to talk about...
There's still like a couple of more announcements...
There's...
There's still like...
A couple of more announcements...
To go...
Okay let me see...
Oh...
Oh my gosh...
It's...
It's my birthday...
I'm gonna...
Give me a sec guys...
I'm gonna open the window...
Because it is getting like really...
Lots of hot air...
I'm talking so much...
I'm yapping so much...
So I'm gonna open the window real quick...
I'll be right back...
I mean I'm still here... You can hear me from far away... I can't open my window...
Alright...
There we go...
I think it's also because I'm like...
Super nervous today...
Like... I have...
So much...
Butterflies going on in my stomach...
So like I feel...
I don't know...
I just feel a lot more...
Like... nervous today...
And it's just a lot of excitement...
And everything because...
Oh...
It's just...
There's so many announcements...
There's so many announcements to do...
There's so many things to talk about...
And...
It's crazy...
It's really crazy...
Um...
Okay...
Alright...
Okay... You know what?
I can show you one of the GIFs...
We'll do one of the GIFs too...
It's like... I don't wanna overwhelm you with announcements...
Back to back to back to back...
So...
We're gonna like...
Make sure...
That like...
We pace ourselves a little bit when it comes to these announcements...
So let me bring the GIF box over...
So...
As you guys can see...
We have a little present!
A little present...
For you guys...
Alright so... I hope I bring out the right present...
I hope it's the...
Correct present...
That I'm gonna open...
So I have a special gift for you guys!
I have a special gift... I have several special gifts...
Well... several as in two...
Um... But like... I guess like...
There's a third one... But it's not like in the box...
Because like... It's like more so of like...
A verbal present...
Hahahaha...
So...
Woooow...
Immersion...
Hahahaha...
Alright...
Let's see... I hope this is the correct...
Is this the correct one?
Oh my gosh... Oh yes!
This one!
Alright... I'm gonna make sure I grab the...
Alright so...
So... So you know like...
Um... For birthdays...
For birthdays...
Um...
You know how there's like...
Birthday merch...
So...
Yaaaaay!
Hahahaha...
So!
This won't be sold yet.
The reason being is that...
I know like, oh you put it out today.
You know, a lot of dragoons are gonna buy it and everything.
A lot of merch is being brought out now.
There's the U2s.
There's the Hyatt stuff.
There's the Nendoroid.
Okay, Nendoroid's pre-order is not out yet.
But you know what I mean.
There's a lot of merch coming out in general.
Especially Hyatt.
The Hyatt collab is very expensive.
So I decided that I'm gonna wait a little bit.
So that, you know, I want you guys to spend money on yourselves.
And you know, be able to save money and everything.
And so it was like...
That's also why I haven't released the BattleBirds merch as well.
And it's always like pay rent.
Because like 300 plus dollars, it's a lot.
It's a lot.
Especially if you convert it to other currencies.
Especially if you convert it to other currencies and everything.
I felt like 300 dollars plus, it is a lot of money.
And like, I'm not here to really make...
Like, I'm not here to be like profit, profit.
Profit, profit, profit.
Like...
And...
Even if you pre-ordered this on my birthday, it's not gonna arrive on my birthday.
Because my birthday is gonna be over in a couple of hours.
So I felt like you guys can wait a little longer.
Since like, when this is...
Like when this comes out.
Um...
You know.
When like people actually...
When people...
If you order it today, it's not even gonna arrive today.
So...
That's why.
But I did want to show you guys.
Like we did have like a birthday merch plan.
But I decided that I wanted to like...
Pace the merch line more.
Due to the fact that, you know, we have the Hyatt Collab pre-orders came out today.
And there's so many other merch stuff and everything.
And also I literally just sold the acrylic stands and everything.
So that's why I decided not to sell it.
And I decided that I wanted to sell the birthday merch today.
Um...
I also want to flesh it out a little bit more.
But yes.
There will be a limited set of these as well.
Where I'll be sending like a signed copy of this.
Because I'm planning...
I'm deciding...
At the...
Um...
Because like I decided not to sell it.
I'm trying to like finalize and put more care into my birthday merch as well.
Um...
But I do have plans to make a limited...
Like there's a limited edition set and there's a normal set.
The limited edition set will be signed.
And the normal set will be like...
You know...
Just unsigned.
And...
So yes.
That's why I decided not to put the birthday merch up yet.
Um...
Just because like I said...
There's...
A lot of things...
Being sold under the Doki Bird brand.
And I don't want to like...
You know...
I'm not here to be like...
Give me all your money.
It's not like...
I...
You guys supported me so much.
And...
You guys supported me so much already.
And because of that...
I...
Like I said...
I didn't want to...
I didn't really want to...
Uh...
Force you guys to like spend more.
Regarding...
Regarding this.
But...
Isn't it cute?
You guys are all in there too.
I requested every dragoon.
Um...
I'm not sure.
I requested...
Every dragoon to be a part of the birthday...
Um...
The birthday merch.
Like the birthday illustration.
And...
Uh...
So like you see that like...
You know...
There's the long goon.
There's the egg goons.
With the little party hats.
There's chonky goons.
There's the regular goons and everything.
And there's dad down there.
At the bottom right.
There's dad.
Um...
So...
Uh...
So yes!
This...
This is one of the gifts...
Um...
That's in this box.
Hahaha!
Putting it back into the box you go.
Alright.
Put the lid back on too.
Alright!
There's more presents but...
Uh...
But I'm gonna put it aside for now.
And...
Cause I wanna talk about other things.
I'm gonna paste my announcements guys.
So...
Hahaha!
I am pasting my announcements.
So...
Shrinking the...
Putting the box back here again.
Uh...
There's a lot more other gifts in...
There's like two more gifts in there too.
Uh...
To look forward to.
But I'm gonna put it away for now.
Alright!
Whoa!
Oh my god!
I'm trying not to like...
Be too overwhelming to you guys.
Hahaha!
I also saw like tweets.
Also the other reason...
You guys were like...
My wallet!
Please don't keep my wallet!
Hahaha!
Haha!
Okay, funny story!
By the way, the Minecraft server stream is a public stream.
The only like exclusive part of it is the fact that it's only members will be white listed to be able to join the Dragoon server.
But the stream itself is a public stream.
Um...
Okay, but funny story.
So...
Apparently...
There was I think 12 of you guys that broke into the server.
Hahaha!
So, or 15.
Okay.
Yes.
Apparently, 15 of you guys broke into the server before the server was supposed to launch.
And I only found out because you guys, like, posted pictures of it on Twitter.
So, like, you know, after, like, behind-scenes work, I was, like, looking through Twitter.
And, like, I saw my For You page of people taking screenshots of the server being like, I beat the Ender Dragon.
We beat the Ender Dragon.
And I was like, what?
Is this my Minecraft server?
I said, so, in two hours.
You guys beat the Ender Dragon in two hours?
Guys, this is supposed to be, like, a multi-month project.
Anyway.
So, I messaged my...
I messaged my...
The Minecraft team.
And they were like, what the fuck?
They were like, that's not supposed to happen.
And then I messaged the team, the Minecraft team.
And they were like, we're so sorry.
Like, we don't know why.
The whitelist just didn't work.
And so, like, so they apparently, one of them, like, went in and kicked all of you guys out.
And the world is reset.
It's reset now.
But they reset everything.
So, don't worry.
Like, you guys can beat the Ender Dragon again in two hours.
Like...
Anyway.
Anyway, everything is reset now.
So, you've lost all your progress.
You have to do it all over again.
That's what you get for breaking in.
Um...
So...
Anyway.
So, the server is fully reset now.
Everything is reset.
Like, all the stuff you had in there is gone.
So, the Ender Dragon is back.
Um...
And everything.
But yes, they fixed it.
The whitelist works now.
Um...
I didn't know the whitelist didn't work.
I was already whitelisted.
So, like, how was I supposed to know that, like...
When I joined in, I assumed the whitelist was working.
Because they told me...
Uh...
Oh, yeah, you're whitelisted now.
But apparently, for some reason, it just stopped working.
Hahaha.
But at least it was 14 of you guys.
So, you guys were, like, literally the beta testers.
It's like...
It's like those, like...
Um...
What is it called?
Those, like, hackers that do it for good.
Like, they're just hacking the show to them.
Like, oh, your data is compromised.
Like, we only hacked you.
So, we can tell you that your data...
Your security is compromised.
And, like, we want you to improve your security.
Hahaha.
Yeah.
I was like...
I was like, what the f...
What do you...
I was like, what do you mean you beat the Ender Dragon?
And I looked through the tweets.
They're like, we got into the Minecraft server two hours later.
We beat the Ender Dragon.
And I'm like...
I was like...
What?
What do you mean you beat the Ender Dragon?
Hahaha.
Thank you for the aqua soup.
Thank you.
Bye, tomato.
Thank you for the aqua soup.
Thank you.
Guys, I'm gonna use the bathroom real quick.
Give me a sec.
I'll be right back, guys.
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
Bathroom break.
Stay hydrated.
All right.
I'm back.
I'm back, everybody.
Um...
Oh, my gosh.
I'm back.
Okay.
So, yeah.
So, that was...
I can't believe you guys...
I can't believe you guys fucking broke into the Minecraft server.
Like, what the fuck?
Oh, my God.
Um...
All right.
I actually wrote notes on like...
Just to be like...
Okay.
Remember to talk about this.
And then remember to talk about that.
And then remember to talk about this.
Um...
Okay.
Let me see.
I'm looking through my notes just to be sure that...
Uh...
Just to be sure that I'm not gonna be like...
Just to make sure that I got like majority of stuff that I want to talk about.
Ah...
Okay.
Whoo!
Um...
I guess like...
I can do my second gift.
I guess it's time to give you guys the second gift.
All right.
I'm bringing the present back.
So...
This gift is unfinished, though.
Um...
It's not done yet.
But I wanted to show you guys.
Uh...
The preview of it.
Um...
I'm gonna do like gift two and three.
Uh...
So it's like second gift and then the third gift.
And then maybe by that time, I can make my final announcement.
I don't know if I stalled enough.
But yes.
Here is my second gift.
Oh.
This is the correct one.
No.
What did I move?
Oh.
This is...
What is that?
Oh.
That's the...
Okay.
That's something else.
I was like...
What was I moving?
Wait.
Where did it go?
Sorry.
I'm gonna mess a little bit.
All right.
Where the fuck did it go?
Where did...
Okay.
I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna resize it.
Sorry.
I can't...
The immersion stops here.
Because I'm just gonna reset...
Reset the transform.
There it is.
Yes!
It is another one!
Okay.
So, some of you guys were like, what is that?
This...
Oh my gosh.
The immersion.
This...
Is an...
This is an artwork drawn by my mama!
My mama drew this.
I thought about whether or not...
To make this as merch.
But...
Because I am already releasing like the birthday merch.
Soon TM.
I guess I wanted to paste stuff.
I will be releasing this for free whenever it's done.
So, you guys can make it...
Merch of it yourself.
You don't have to like buy this as a merch.
So, I will be releasing this.
This...
For free.
Whenever it's done.
Since I already...
I mean you guys are gonna be...
Since I already planned on releasing like...
I don't want like two prints like...
So...
This...
Whenever my mama is done with this illustration, it will be free for all dragons to download in the future.
It won't be like paywall or anything.
I will be releasing this for free.
Just because I already have like the birthday merch print and everything.
I just didn't feel like I needed to really...
Like you can make it merch as for yourself.
Like I don't...
Like I don't really mind.
You guys are like...
Yogi wanna pay you.
That's what BattleBirds merch is for.
We're like...
We're like coming up with a huge line for BattleBirds.
Like we're gonna make an art book and everything.
Like a hardcover limited edition art book and stuff.
We're gonna make it up with like text and like notes and everything from all the people that went...
Like made it.
And then we're gonna have like a special merch being made for BattleBirds.
That's what BattleBirds is for.
Like I don't wanna like spam you guys with merch.
Cause like...
Like...
You guys gotta look after your wallets.
You know?
You guys...
I want you guys to like you know have enough for rent and food and the internet.
Cause like without the internet, how are you gonna watch me?
Um...
So that's why...
And I know shipping is crazy expensive too.
So like...
That's why like I'm pacing my...
My merch in general.
Um...
Just cause like you know...
I don't really...
Um...
Like I know like merch is a lot of profit.
But like...
I'm not here for like insane profit.
Like I'm just here to have a good time.
Like I don't wanna fucking bleed you guys dry.
Like what the f...
Um...
Just casually...
What?
We talked about the art book before!
We talked about it during the behind the scenes!
What do you mean?
I dropped a bombshell!
Like we were talking about the fucking possibility of making an art book regarding the production behind.
Um...
Battlebirds.
Like it's not like...
I didn't confirm...
Okay it's confirmed.
Um...
We're like...
I'm like scouting...
Like we're...
I'm like scouting out like a...
Um...
Like a person that can publish art books and stuff.
Like self-publish art books.
Um...
Cause there's just so many amazing artwork and uh...
Work in progress and concept art that went into the production behind Battlebirds in general.
Um...
So that's why like...
Uh...
That's why I'm like...
I'm like...
That's why like it's gonna take time.
Um...
To like have all that planned and when...
Cause like I don't wanna like rush it as well.
I want merch that is something that you guys really want and um...
There's quality going into it.
I'm not wanna re...
Like I'm...
I don't...
I don't wanna reuse illustrations for like 500 different types of merch and stuff.
I like having like unique illustration for like a unique certain merch line.
So like um...
Like this illustration will be for this merch and uh...
This illustration will be for that merch.
Cause I like to put like care and thought into it.
I feel like I don't wanna reprint it for like various other things.
Um...
Because like that's not...
As somebody that like collects stuff.
Like as a consumer...
I rather have quality...
Uh...
Over quantity.
Just cause like I want...
I want...
The merch to have special meaning.
Uh...
Especially like when I'm putting thought into it.
I like having...
Cause as someone that used to sell at Artist Alley.
Like I...
Um...
I like having special meaning when it comes to like what merch is.
Speaking of like future merch.
I did not...
I hope like...
Uh...
The artist is okay for me.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so excited to show you guys this one.
Okay.
Speaking of like merch with special meaning and making like a special merch for certain things.
Uh...
Okay.
I don't know when this will be done.
Because we're still designing the concept of it.
But like...
Uh...
Sorry.
Oh my gosh.
I ruined the immersion.
Let me put the lid down.
Let me put the lid on this real fast.
Um...
Alright.
I'm putting it behind me.
It's a little crooked this lid.
Let me...
Okay.
There we go.
I know you guys would be like super annoyed at the crooked lid.
But...
Oh my gosh.
I need to show you guys this one.
Um...
This is the...
This was not part of my announcements.
But like I really wanted to show you guys this.
Uh...
Okay.
Let's see.
Is this...
Okay.
Wait.
Whoops.
Not this one.
Sorry.
Give me a sec.
I need to like...
It's so hard to put away the presents guys.
Wait.
I need to save it.
Okay.
I need to find it.
Um...
I'm sorry.
If the...
Look.
I'm...
Um...
I'm sorry if like...
Uh...
But...
I'm sorry.
If like...
Um...
Cause like...
I don't think the artist would know I was gonna show this.
But...
I...
I really...
I thought it was a really good segue.
Because...
Fuck it.
I'm spoiling you guys.
It's my birthday.
But like...
We're a team.
So I'm gonna spoil you guys.
Um...
I saw some people saw the Garfield.
Guys.
If you're gonna buy a...
Uh...
You're gonna buy...
A Tokey Bird Nendoroid.
And you also have...
The Garfield Nendoroid.
Can you like...
Take a picture of the two of us together?
Okay.
I need to show you guys this.
Alright.
So.
I'm super excited.
I don't know when this will be done.
But like...
When it is done...
I'm super excited to make this merch.
Cause I feel like you guys will love this.
I'm gonna show you guys.
Um...
The Doki coin is going to be real!
There's gonna be a heads version.
I'll assume this is tails, the tails side.
But you know like those like coins, like those giant coins and everything.
Um, like the with them blah blah and blasting and stuff.
Um...
Those giant coins.
We're gonna be making a Doki coin.
Um...
And we're currently... I'm currently it's like in the draft stages at the moment.
Um, but this is something I thought that you guys are gonna...
I thought you guys are gonna love.
Um, but yes, it's gonna be like an actual coin.
Like those giant novelty...
You know those giant novelty coins?
You know what I'm talking about?
With like textures and everything like those like, uh, Those like textures on the gold and stuff.
Yes!
Real Doki coin will be made.
Like a physical... a physical coin.
Um, and not like the time coins like the bigger ones.
So, uh, it's gonna come with like a box and everything.
Um...
So yeah, yeah like a medallion.
Yes, similar to a medallion.
Um, and I don't know what this could be take like months or whatever.
But when it's when we finally figure this out.
When the design for heads is done as well.
Um...
I'm definitely going to...
Um, I'm going to like, uh, you know like, uh, we'll give like pre-orders up for this.
But I'm super excited for this merch.
Like I said, I like I want to like...
Play around with like merch like now that like, you know having...
Um the choice to like design like have creative control of like what to make and stuff like that.
Um...
I'm super excited.
Um, really really excited to see where that's going.
Anyway...
Um, let me see.
Uh, I'm gonna like message the staff team to see like, uh, see like if I still have to...
If I still have to stop regarding the final announcement.
Okay, the funny thing is that um, my staff team, uh, sent my Asia team sent me like a long list of like, okay, this is the final two announcements to make.
Um, but they're like, okay, but we need to make sure like...
You can make this announcement and I was like, okay, it was a long list.
Like it was like they're like here are the talking points.
And I was like, wow, that's why I was like, I was like there's more.
That's why yesterday I tweeted out.
I was like there's more.
I was just like what?
Oh my god.
I was just like what do you mean there's more stuff to talk about?
So three, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday.
Dogecoin.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Okay.
Um, the third gift is a spoiler for the next.
Oh wait.
Sorry.
I forgot.
I'm gonna like, uh, give you guys a cliffhanger.
I forgot to message my my staff team.
Okay.
All right.
Next one, dogecoin.
Next one.
Okay, okay, um, the the the third, um gift is a when you hydrate
When you blow my nose, give me a sec
Give me a sec.
I need a moment.
What do you mean?
How is this even?
You guys got fed.
You guys got overfed.
You can't call it evil anymore.
You guys literally got overfed.
Anyway, um the next, uh, oh wait.
The next gift that, um, I want to give you guys
Is that, um, I was in talks, um with, um Okay, give me a guys give me a sec i'm gonna uh, I'm joking.
I'm joking.
Um, anyway, so, um, basically I was in talks, uh with tempo And if you guys didn't know um tempo is uh one of I guess like you say one of the few many big organizers of um apex tournaments and apex events um, so I was in talks with him and you know how he gets like huge prize pools and everything for Apex events and everything like,
you know, he has done like 25k prize pools to like 100k from all the way to minimum 25k to maximum like 150k 150,000 us dollars for prize pools and stuff.
Um, and we've always had these talks.
We've always had these talks and I was like, cause like he always wanted to host something for vtubers and um, this last this week.
And I was like, cause like he always wanted to host something for vtubers and um, this last this week.
Um, we were talking about it.
I was like, do you want to do it like for my next event?
and um We are currently uh, I think we had a date established too.
We were
So Uh, this will be a spiritual successor of sorts.
Uh, Uh, it's not gonna be a tournament.
It is gonna be a custom and Uh, we are planning on oh my gosh Okay, give me a second.
I need to pull up my tempo chat logs because he gave me dates and I was just like I just I already forgot there's so much stuff going on
It would either be on Uh, september 28th or uh october 5th um We've established like dates for it And i'm announcing it now And i'm announcing it now We're getting interest right now because um Participants will be invite It'll be invited participants as in we'll be inviting like I guess like quote unquote team captains But it's a custom.
So if you guys don't know it's not gonna be tournament.
It's not gonna be screaming Um, it's gonna be like fun match serious match fun match serious match fun match and the prizes won't be like currency It won't be money But the prize pool Will equal a lot of money as in like the prizes will because like maybe like one of the fun matches like oh and like The maybe we'll have like one will be like hide and seek match and like the team that The team that hides the best like the team that survives in the end will win a pc like each person gets a pc or like a 40 80 stuff like that like or like an exclusive like apex legends like merch or
We are in talks at the moment.
Obviously, the bigger interest this event will get, this custom will get, the bigger sponsors we can have to provide better prizes.
Each game will have its own trophy and its own prize.
So like each game, everybody type and then every participant will receive like a little memorabilia similar to WrestleTuber.
I talked to Tempo and we were like, should we gather interest privately or publicly?
I decided to make it public that plans are public.
So we are in motion because the prizes gets more...
I guess the prize pool and budget and sponsors are more lucrative the higher interest we get.
And the more interest we get from VTubers.
This custom will be open to NA and APAC VTubers.
It will only be VTubers.
And it has to be like full on like VTubing type deal.
So I'm sorry EU.
I'm really sorry EU.
I'm really sorry EU but we had to make a decision on NA EU or NA APAC.
Due to servers issue.
So we decided to make it NA.
We had to make a very tough decision.
Regarding like the VTubers that will be participating.
It's not V-Cycle.
It's a 4 fun...
It's a 4 fun custom.
And similar to like it's just for fun.
We're gonna have more fun matches than serious matches.
Because we have so many customs.
We have so many tournaments.
That's like super serious and everything.
And I told Tempo.
I was like I don't want like prize money for this.
Like I don't want people to win prize money.
I want like prizes.
Because I feel like when you do prizes.
When you do prizes.
People tend to make it more fun in general.
And not take it as serious as like money.
So that's why some of them will be like you know more like fun prizes.
Like maybe plushies or like Apex plushies.
Or like maybe one of them will be like a computer.
The serious one will be a computer.
But each team that wins like a game in this custom.
Will receive like a little like medal or a trophy.
It depends.
I'm like still working all the details out at the moment.
Like I said like this is still like in the works.
So now we're just getting interest.
We're garnering interest.
To see like who wants to like to see like participant who might be interested in it.
Because I'll be like.
I'll be inviting people.
To see gather interest by inviting Vtubers.
And like I don't want to make it full on centric.
Like Apex Vtubers only can join.
This is why I'm focusing heavily on the fun aspect of it.
Because I wanted so that the fun aspect.
So I'm opening invites to people who don't normally stream Apex.
Or are not very great at it.
But FPS just for the sake that you know people tend to not play FPS.
Might really enjoy the melee.
You know the melee only.
Or like only melees and stuff like that.
And yeah.
So that is my next event.
I don't know what to call it yet.
Like I said like Temple and I were literally talking about this.
This week.
And I decided to use my birthday to announce them.
My next event.
Just like in the past.
I want to use my birthday to announce the next event that is in the works at the moment.
I think you guys know like Shibuya Hau is definitely like one of my role models.
As well as Amelia Watson.
Shibuya Hau for his amazing like organization skills.
When it comes to like tournaments like the Shibuya Hau customs and everything.
He has a lot of fun.
And he has been like a great role model and inspiration to me when it comes to organizing tournaments and events.
The fact that he is able to do that and like make a...
Um...
Make a...
I guess like image and like presence for himself.
Regarding FPS games in general.
And being able to organize like all these events regarding FPS stuff.
And having a team behind it.
And like his like V-Psycho stuff is so famous in Japan.
To the point that like when I was in Japan.
I would see like V-Psycho merch being sold with like regular Apex merch.
Like in a mall.
I felt like at that point like that's like crazy to think about.
Um...
How...
Like how Shibuya Hau is like...
How it made such an impact when it comes to...
Um...
When it comes to like Apex and stuff.
And like just like events as well.
Like CR Raccoon.
Like CR...
You can say like oh there's like crazy raccoon events.
That's like organized by like an entire company.
And Shibuya Hau is like a person.
Like a singular...
Like you know you say crazy raccoon tournaments in Japan.
And crazy raccoon tournaments...
The whole image behind it is like...
Uh...
The org itself.
But like...
Um...
I think like Shibuya Hau has...
Does have teams behind him.
But he does do a lot of work.
Uh...
Behind the tournaments as well.
Like he started organizing these tournaments himself.
To a point that it grew so big in Japan.
That like his merch is sold in like...
His merch is sold in like malls and stuff.
Like um...
And you can see it being placed right next to like regular Apex stuff.
And like other like famous like anime merch and everything.
And so he's like an incredible inspiration to me when it comes to like organizing FPS tournaments and everything.
Like I got a lot of inspiration from the stuff he's done in the past.
As well as like...
For Ami...
Um...
I talked about this a lot in the past.
So it's not like...
Oh...
She's mentioning Ami for the first time.
No...
I've talked about it a lot.
Um...
But yeah like...
Uh...
I feel like she's really great at organizing things.
And like...
Was such a pioneer when it came to like what a singular VTuber can do.
And like in terms of like hosting events.
And hosting like...
Uh...
Projects and everything.
Um...
I feel like I wouldn't have been able to...
Uh...
Organize the things I've organized without like...
Um...
The fact that Ami inspired me a lot to do these types of things.
Uh...
To see her motivation drive...
When she started and like...
Pioneered a lot of stuff within the VTubing community.
Um...
So I wouldn't have been able to do all of this without like...
Uh...
Her taking the first steps.
Um...
First steps in starting these big projects herself.
So...
Yeah...
And...
Um...
Also like I know it's hard like...
Crazy Raccoon has also done so much too.
Regarding organization and stuff.
And...
Um...
They've like...
They're really great at organizing tournaments.
And I really wish that we do have more of these types of things in the VTubing community.
Um...
And...
I'm really...
I hope that like...
You know...
Uh...
This Apex Custom...
Will go well!
I hope...
I do hope this Apex Custom...
Will go well.
Um...
We're still...
We're still like...
Drafting it up.
And everything...
Like I said like...
Uh...
Tempo was telling me like...
We need to...
Gather interest.
And see who's actually willing to commit to it.
Um...
To...
Approach sponsors and everything.
Um...
To be able to approach sponsors.
And like get like the definite prize pool.
Of everything.
So...
Yeah!
Um...
Alright!
Let me look at what my staff said.
If I can.
Uh...
Okay.
So...
We're still starting.
Alright.
Before...
Okay.
I'm gonna start one more time.
One last time.
Uh...
New goals.
There's something I wanted to do.
So...
I'm gonna start...
This is what I wanted to do.
Oh...
The final song.
If it's not ready...
I will announce this last thing another time.
And by the time I made the...
The goals list...
And...
And it's not ready...
I will announce the last thing another time.
Okay.
Alright.
No, there's more.
There's one last announcement.
There's one...
Okay.
All right.
New goals.
This is why I told you guys, I don't want to make a new goals list until, until like a lot of these things got announced because, uh, because then I would spoil the goals that I've accomplished behind the scenes.
I was like, cause I was like, you know, my previous goals, it was like, Ooh, I want, uh, no, the Apex custom was not a star.
It was a gift, a gift to spoil you guys what the next event was going to be, what my next big event was going to be.
So like, we're not going to have like event announcement, like what they've so like by the time, by the time we're at a stage where we're like the, the event announcement for this apex custom, it's not going to be like secret.
We'll have like a full on like logo and everything ready in like a stream to announce teams and everything.
Anyway, like I said, um, um, I didn't want to do the goals list until, uh, on my birthday, because in previous goals list, I wrote, I want to figure, well, I want to figure I want to nendoroid.
Well, it would be awkward if I didn't put that again, um, before the nendoroid announcement.
So I waited until majority announcements were made.
So we can have that.
So we can have an actual real goals list.
Um, oh, fuck.
I just remembered there was another goal in there that we accomplished that hasn't been announced.
That's which one is it?
Okay.
JK.
There's actually like one more goal in there that, uh, JK.
That we accomplished behind the scenes, but I can't say because now, now it's time for you guys to figure it out.
Now it's your turn to figure it out.
What it could be.
Also, I'm going to tell them my staff that like, I'm going to stop for 30 more minutes.
If in 30 minutes.
Okay.
I had a very long day today.
I started my day at 8 AM.
I'll stop for 30 more, more minutes.
Okay.
30 more minutes.
And then I end stream.
Okay.
All right.
So.
This is definitely one that we all know that really want to do.
Um, let's see.
We okay.
Shit.
Okay.
Give me a sec guys.
I'm going to, I'm going to disappear real quick on screen because like, I'm going to type like numbers and then you're going to see like a million toggles go on.
So I'm going to disappear for like one second.
Don't be like, where did Doki go?
Give me a sec guys.
Okay.
There you go.
I guess gotta make sure I just gotta make sure.
All right.
Uh, poof.
I'm back.
All right.
This one.
1 million subscribers.
I, I'm tired.
I can't even spell right now.
Before end of 2024.
Actually, I don't even know if that's possible anymore.
I don't, I don't know.
It's actually a little scary.
Cause like, I don't know.
It's so, it'll suck if we don't hit it.
It would actually really suck.
Cause people like, well, failed goal.
So, um, I'm scared.
I'm worried.
Should I like before end of January at 2025.
Okay.
Here we go.
I gave us a little bit of leeway.
Just, just a little bit of leeway here.
So 1 million before end of January 2025.
Um, don't sit.
Fine.
Okay.
Before end of 2025.
Fine.
If you guys were so, you guys are so confident.
All right.
1 million subscribers before end of 2024.
That is awesome.
Okay.
So my new goal, um, another goal.
I would love to have a Funko pop Funko pop.
Do you hear that guys?
Funko pop.
I'll be your first VTuber, your first VTuber Funko.
I'm marketable.
I think.
I mean, I'm having an Android.
I should be marketable now.
I need to complete the tribal.
Triangle!
I have the YouTube's figure!
I have the Nendoroid!
I need to complete the triangle!
I'm missing...
I'm missing the Funko Pop!
We need a summoning... like how am I supposed to complete the summoning circle without the Funko Pop?
We have the normie audience!
We have the flesh... we need... okay, we have the flesh too because YouTube's there's a lot of like the the YouTube the YouTuber sometimes like flesh tuber audience the youtuber slash flesh tuber audience We have the otaku slash anime audience and now we need the normie audience We need the Funko Pop This is how you summon Doki
We're nearly we're nearly missing the Funko Pop Anyway, uh, but yes, that is one of the two goals that I really do wanna, uh...
I feel like... No!
It would not ruin... It would not ruin the magic circle.
Because if we get a deal with Funko Pop, then I'll have, like, so many versions of me.
Like, we'll have enough Funkos to make an entire circle.
We're gonna have a flocked version of Doki.
We're gonna have the, like, one foot tall Funko Doki.
We're gonna have the metallic Doki.
We're gonna have the, uh...
We're gonna have the feminized Doki Bird.
We're gonna have...
We're gonna have so many...
Guys, the moment we get that Funko deal, we will have so many alternate versions of Doki.
We're gonna have the glow-in-the-dark Doki.
We're gonna make the entire circle with Funko Pop.
Think about it, guys.
And then the normie...
Look, guys, the normie audience is gonna be like, we have to collect all the Dokis.
Okay, guys?
This is how...
Doki, I thought you said you're not for profit.
This is, like, such a capitalistic thing to do.
Okay, look.
I make exceptions.
And that is for Funko Pop.
My one exception is for Funko Pop.
Because I want all the different alternatives when it comes to Funko.
Alright.
Anyway.
Other goals.
Oh my gosh, where did my goals list go?
Oh no.
Oh, there it is.
Okay, I think this is it.
Yeah, no, that's not it.
Oh no.
Where did my goals list go?
Oh, here it is.
Okay.
Anyway.
That's, like...
And then we get featured in the Funko Pop game alongside Funko Freddy Fazbear!
Exactly!
That, that, that...
You know how capitalism works.
Alright.
Another goal.
Get a pro player to use my merch...
To use my gaming...
Gamer gear on...
In a tournament.
Alright.
Guys, please somebody get good so you can bring Doki merch to a tournament.
That's all I want.
Alright.
Okay.
Uh...
That's one of my goals.
Another goal that I have.
Um...
Okay, this is a very personal goal.
I wanna...
This is something I really...
Cause like, I feel like I really want to motivate myself.
You know, like I've strayed away from like, um...
I've been more variety.
Um, as of late.
But like...
I feel like...
I wanna get back into like...
Being competitive.
In a way.
Not more so like...
More so like...
I wanna get back into leaderboard grinding.
Um...
But like not like forcing it on stream type deal.
I won't like...
You know, I won't be like stream spamming rank all the time type deal.
But it's more so like...
A little personal goal for myself.
Um...
I won't be spamming the streams for these.
But like when I get close to it...
Maybe I'll like stream the climb.
The like last remaining climb to it.
Um...
But...
I...
Um...
In...
This is...
This is a goal I've been thinking about a lot.
In...
Uh...
2 July...
Oh wait.
Within...
A year...
I want to get...
On the leaderboards...
For 4 different games.
Um...
So...
This is a little...
Personal goal of mine.
Uh...
I want to be...
Any...
For any competitive game...
I want to...
Be on a leaderboards for 4 different games.
It doesn't...
They don't have to be on the same season.
That's crazy.
Hahaha...
But...
I want to do this in 4 different games.
Uh...
Within a year.
So...
Within a year...
Uh...
July...
So...
On my...
On next year's birthday...
I would have accomplished...
4...
4 games...
4 different games...
Being on the leaderboards.
And...
And not the leaderboards.
So I don't want to touch it.
I want to end on the leaderboards.
And this is a little personal...
Oh...
Hey...
Hey dad...
The fuck?
Okay...
I just felt like his nose touched my leg.
And I was like...
Oh...
You know like cold...
Cold noses.
Why are you here?
Hahaha...
So...
Um...
That's something I want to do.
So within a year.
Okay...
Let me...
Bop bop bop...
Uh...
July 2025.
I feel like this is so doable.
This is definitely really doable.
Hahaha...
And this is like a personal goal of mine.
That I...
Do you want...
What?
Do you want to play this?
What do you want?
I have no food.
What do you...
What do you want?
I have no food.
What do you want, dad?
He's being needy.
I don't know where he gets it from.
She's that confident?
Okay!
Okay, I'm sorry, but like...
Guys, top 500 for Overwatch was Masters...
Two.
Guys, that's one game I've already fucking...
Can get it.
Last season's...
Last season's top 500 for Overwatch was my...
I fucking can knock that off the park.
Because no one... Look, I said four different games.
I did say... That's why I said four.
I said...
That's why... That's why I said four.
So that's why...
That's why, like... I feel like...
I feel like I can accomplish it.
And I feel like this is also a personal goal for myself.
Just to get back into the swing of things.
Because I haven't been able to get much into competitive gaming.
Dad, I'm having a stream!
I don't... Okay.
Guys, this is a little TMI.
But...
Okay, guys.
Okay, here's a little TMI about Dad.
He likes feet.
Um... What do you mean by that?
Well, the reason why he's...
The reason why he's barking...
Is that...
He wanted me to...
To extend my leg.
And like pet him.
With my... With my foot.
So you can tell.
He stopped barking, right?
Okay, so this is...
I am king shaming him.
I am.
Okay.
Alright.
Anyway.
But he stopped barking.
So...
These are the sacrifices we have to make, guys.
This is the sacrifice...
This is the...
This is the sacrifices we have to make.
Oh my God, Dad.
Are you serious?
Are you...
Are you fucking serious?
Alright.
Look, I stopped petting him.
I stopped scratching him.
So...
We'll see what happens after...
Let's see what happens.
Um...
What was I gonna say?
Okay, so...
Other than that...
Don't really have...
Any other goals.
I don't know.
I don't know any goals to...
Oh, he left.
Okay.
We're not gonna analyze that.
He left.
Okay.
Um...
He got what he wanted.
Okay.
Um...
I don't know.
I don't know what other goals to aim for.
Other than...
Um...
Other than, like...
Other than that.
Because it's like...
There's...
We already accomplished so much.
And...
We already accomplished so much together.
Dragoons.
That...
It's so hard to think of new things to do.
New things to aim for.
That's why I had...
I had...
That's why I had this personal goal of mine.
To have.
Cause it's my own personal goal of mine.
As a competitive gamer.
Because like...
Obviously there's so much stuff going on.
Behind the scenes.
There's a lot of stuff going on behind the scenes.
That like I wasn't able to be...
Like game...
In a more competitive sense in a while.
Like I haven't been able to play a lot of...
FPS games or play competitive games.
Off stream a lot.
Because there's just so many things going on for me.
But I hope things...
Start to cool down by mid July.
That I can go back.
To my roots.
And...
And like you know...
I want to have my name.
I want to have Doki Bird.
And no other name.
I want Doki...
I want...
I want Doki Bird to be like...
On the leaderboards.
That's that Vtuber.
That's that Vtuber on the leaderboards.
Right there in this game.
That got there.
And I want to do it on stream too.
On stream.
And show you guys.
Look!
There she is!
On stream!
Getting that...
Staying in that leaderboard!
Hahahaha!
Um...
So...
That's something I really want to do.
Um...
I guess like...
I want to get that in for like...
Um...
For like a personal goal of mine.
Oh!
There's one!
There's another personal goal.
Win some form of Vtuber award.
Hahahaha!
It's like...
Um...
Win a cat...
Win some form of category in a Vtuber award.
As Doki Bird.
Um...
Where's my goals list?
There you go.
That's my final goal.
Win a cat...
A category for a Vtuber award.
Yeah.
I think...
That is...
I don't know.
I don't know if there's anything I want to do.
Other than these.
Um...
I would love to win a category...
For a...
For a Vtuber award.
It doesn't matter what category.
I'm fine with any.
I just want one.
Hahahaha!
I just...
I just want one in general.
So...
Let's just hope in the future.
At the end of the year.
Because it's almost award season.
It's almost the end of the year.
We all know what happens at the end of the year.
Every fucking award season.
Hahahaha!
So...
Uh...
That's hope...
I hope that's possible.
I really do.
Especially as...
As Doki.
Um...
But yeah...
I think that's really...
That's really like...
I guess like...
All the things I really want to accomplish within the year.
Or like not within the year.
But like for my long term goals.
At this point.
It's hard to think of new goals these days.
Because it's like...
I accomplished so much.
Despite how short time...
I've been around.
Um...
It's been what?
6 months?
Hahaha!
It's been...
Damn!
It's actually been like...
It's been 6 months right?
7 months?
Has it been 7 or 6 months?
I've honestly lost track.
Hahaha!
Um...
I've honestly like...
Lost track of...
Um...
Lost track of everything.
In terms of like time.
5 months?!
It's only been 5 m...
Oh my god!
Hahaha!
Has it really only been...
5 months?!
That's crazy!
Oh my gosh!
I did not realize...
That...
5 months has passed in like...
Gosh!
I've fucking been speed running.
Hahaha!
I've fucking been like speed running...
Like my fucking...
Vtuber career.
Dad you're not...
Dad's parking outside my door.
Hahaha!
Um...
Yeah...
Oh my god.
I...
It's hard to believe that it's actually 5 months.
Hahaha!
For all of this happening.
Um...
But like...
Honestly like...
Uh...
No guys!
Don't enable!
We're not here to enable behaviors!
Guys!
Everybody!
We're here to like...
Wait!
You've been inside this entire time?
Oh my god!
I thought...
Hahaha!
Wait!
Where were you?
Hahaha!
He's just...
He's actually been in my room this entire time!
Hahaha!
Okay!
Oh my god!
When did you...
What?
Where were you?
He was sitting behind me!
Oh my god!
He was like...
Sitting behind me!
This entire time!
I didn't notice!
Oh my god!
I... Cause like...
When I opened the door...
To like let him out...
He like... just...
He like... He wasn't there!
Cause like I didn't look down when I opened the door.
I opened the door and then I waited.
And then I looked down and he wasn't there.
So I assumed he left.
But he was sitting behind me this entire time!
I didn't even...
Cause then when I heard the barking I was like...
Okay fine!
I'm gonna let you in!
Like I was like... Fuck it!
I'll... Fine!
I'm gonna let you in!
And then... I looked down and there he was!
In my room!
Leave!
Hahaha!
Okay!
Now...
Now he's gone!
Now he's...
Now he's actually gone!
Hahaha!
Oh my god!
Um... He's gone for real now!
He's left... He's left the room!
Okay what was I saying?
God damn it dad!
Hahaha!
He fucking distracted me!
I don't remember what...
He distracted my conversation... my fucking...
Topic!
I don't remember what was on!
Um...
What was I talking about?
Fuck!
Hahaha!
Don't blame him!
He's a good boy!
Oh yeah!
Um...
Huh!
But yeah...
It's...
It's... It's crazy...
Um... Just to think about...
Because like... You know...
Okay I'm gonna get mushy here!
I'm gonna get mushy!
Before...
Because you know... We still have to...
We still have to make a wish!
We still have to blow our candles!
But... I'm gonna get mushy here!
Guys!
I'm gonna get... Uh...
Really mushy here!
But...
Um... You know... After...
Um... Everything...
Like I'm gonna get a little emotional!
Hahaha!
A little...
A little emotional here!
Um...
But...
After like... Everything that happened...
Um...
You know... I...
Did not... You know... I thought...
My life... As a...
Content creator...
Was over!
And... Um...
That really like...
All the hard work... And like all the effort...
To make I Smile and Laugh...
Would be like... Gone... Basically...
Uh... And...
But... I'm still here!
I'm still here!
And...
Uh...
You know like... Some people...
Don't even get their like... First...
Big break...
Like their first lucky big break...
Cause... You know... Making it...
Really relies on...
A lot of luck... Uh...
I always said like... To make it big...
It's mostly about luck...
And how you capitalize on it...
And... But...
I got second... I got two...
And...
If one... If the one percent...
Is making it...
The first time... As like your lucky big break...
Having the opportunity...
To do it...
A second time...
Is like... Finding a...
Leprechaun...
It's like... Actually like...
The 0.0000001% To do it...
A second time...
And...
To basically have like... A restart...
Um... And...
Um...
Is...
Really crazy to think about...
That...
I was able to accomplish all of this...
As an indie... Cause...
Normally you don't see...
Indies... Getting these...
Opportunities... And...
Getting... These...
Things... Like...
I think like... Um...
Especially women like... Um...
I guess like... NA slash EU...
Vtubers... Um... Before me...
Only like...
What... ShyLily and Shoto...
Had Nendoroids...
Um...
For like... Indie Vtubers...
In the western side...
So... To be like... Now...
It's Philly and I... We both got...
Nendoroids now... Um...
And... It's...
Crazy to think about...
Because... You would normally think...
That...
You know... You have to be...
Uh... Under a...
Corporate banner... To be able to achieve...
A lot of these things... Um...
And... Yeah... You can say like...
Oh... But Doki... Like... You've...
You've worked under these conditions before...
And you benefit from... That...
Um...
But... I...
Now I'm just an indie...
Um... I don't really have...
The support structures...
That comes with being in a company...
And... Um...
And...
I don't really have like... You know...
And... I had to do a lot of this...
With my own team that I created...
Uh... And...
Being able to go through it...
Like... Day by day... That's why I've been overwhelmed...
A lot too... Behind the scenes...
Um... Because it was...
It's a lot of work...
It's a lot...
To do it all...
I don't know how the other indies...
Do it... Um...
But... It's why I haven't been like...
Really active... I mean...
I've never really been active on...
Interacting on Twitter...
Um... So... I don't know how...
Other big indies interact on Twitter...
A lot... And like...
Do like... Social media...
Really well...
When I see Shy Lily...
Replying to like... So many tweets...
And like... Watching... And like... Supporting...
So many other Vtubers...
I don't know how she has all that time...
To do that... I really admire her...
Um... Because like...
Um... During the Skinsuit...
Um... Skinsuit...
Debut... Like... Um...
Um... Day after...
Shy Lily messaged me... Like... In support...
And was like... Oh my god... This is such an amazing...
Debut... And everything...
And all that stuff... And like... The fact that she...
Like... Took that extra step to like...
You know... Interact with me... Um...
On... Like...
Discord... As well as like... Like... On...
Social media... Like...
I don't know how she finds the time...
To balance all of this... Like...
She is... Incredibly hardworking...
Being able to balance all of that...
Cause I'm still learning...
I'm... I'm... I'm...
I'm still learning...
I don't... I don't know...
How people do this...
Even Mint... Mint...
Is able to balance... So... Like...
You know... Like... Mint is able to balance...
Like... Interacting with others...
Um... In a much... Much...
Much more personal level... When it comes to like...
Um...
Social media interactions... And like...
Stuff with her own streams... And like...
Her own behind the scenes work as well...
And... I'm still learning!
I'm still learning...
Oh my gosh... It's...
It's a lot of work...
It's definitely a lot...
Thank you for the Akasupa...
Thank you... Thank you... Happy birthday...
Thank you... Um... I accomplished so much...
And we're so proud of you for all the hard work...
And passion... You put into your career and community...
Six months ago... Did you imagine you'd get this far?
No... Absolutely not...
Hahaha... Um... I didn't even think...
I was gonna get a Nendoroid...
We hope you're happy and look forward to the future...
Thank you... Thank you for the Akasupa... Thank you... Thank you...
I hope I'll get more figures in the future...
Like... I hope I'll get a scaled figure...
Um... In the future... Um...
I didn't put in a goals list... Because...
You know... I don't wanna ask for too much... I already have...
A... I think like... Having a Nendoroid...
Is like...
To the point where you know... You sort of...
Made it... type deal...
Because like... Um...
It's a fucking Nendoroid...
Hahaha...
Hahaha... That's like... Sort of like...
When you know... Like...
You sort of... You've made it...
Hahaha...
Like... You're literally...
You're... You're... You're a Dem!
You're her!
Hahaha...
That's me!
So that's why I didn't put scale figure... Because I'm like...
Alright... I don't wanna ask for too much right now...
Hahaha... I already got that...
Hahaha...
Um...
But like I said... Um...
I couldn't have done it without my dragoons...
Uh... For like... Supporting me...
This far...
And to like... Take me there... You know...
Like... Hahaha...
To like... Uh...
Get me here... Like...
In my journey as a content creator...
And...
Yeah... Like... Ah!
Okay... I've done it without you guys...
And that's why I always try to include you guys as much as I can...
In like... Different things...
Like collabs... Or like merch...
And everything... Um...
Because like... I won't be here...
Without... You know...
You can't get far without the support of your fans...
And... And viewers...
I mean... Fans viewers... Hahaha...
Hahaha...
It's the same thing... Redundant... Hahaha...
Unless you're a... You're a hate watcher...
Then I guess you're a viewer... Hahaha...
Hahaha... But... You know what I mean...
Hahaha...
But...
You know what I mean...
Um... Like... It doesn't even matter...
Like... You know... Super chats... Like... Super Chats...
Uh... Hahaha... Super Chats...
Uh... Memberships...
Watching... Subscribing...
Buying merch... Um...
All that stuff... Uh... Getting me opportunities...
Like... Sponsor opportunities...
Uh...
Getting the people to invite me to conventions...
Uh... Tell... Uh...
Letting game companies know I exist...
And like... Inviting me to these opportunities...
And everything...
Uh... I couldn't do without you guys...
I didn't realize how many dragoons are in like...
Various... Different avenues...
Like... When... In various companies and stuff...
Like...
It's actually crazy... Finding out like...
There's a dragoon working in this...
Company... And like...
They want to sponsor me because of that... Like...
Oh my gosh... Like... That's actually...
It's actually really crazy...
To think about sometimes...
Like... People in power...
Like... Watch...
Little old me... Do dumb stuff...
So...
Uh... I really...
I really appreciate it... I really...
I really do... Um...
Yeah!
Okay...
Alright... So...
It's time to make...
A birthday wish...
I don't know...
I don't know what to wish for...
But let's...
Turn off...
The lights...
Oh wait... Sorry...
Don't worry... I have a remote... Guys...
Okay... Um... Guys... I have a remote control...
So like... You see behind me?
You would think behind me...
Is like... The actual outside...
But actually...
Behind me... Has been like...
A green screen this entire time...
So like... Watch this guys...
I'm gonna... Watch this... I'm gonna...
Change this channel on my green screen guys...
Whoa!
No way!
Yes... So...
I was never outside...
It was a green screen...
This entire time...
Um...
She downed the sun...
Real...
Yes!
I changed...
The channel... Um...
Doki controls the sun...
It was a green screen...
This entire time...
Never went outside...
Alright...
Dragwon... You guys...
You guys should get closer...
Dragwon...
I need you guys to like...
Move a little... Shoot me a little closer...
Okay... We're gonna put a hat here...
Okay...
We're gonna...
Make you... Get a little closer...
That's right... Come here Dragwon...
Come here... Where did you go?
I need you to come to the... I need you to come to the table...
Dragwon...
And sit with... Sit with us...
Us as in... Yeah... I'm gonna get dad here too...
Oh wait... I...
Fuck... I forgot...
Alright...
Get over here...
Where are you?
Where the fuck are you guys?
Guys...
No... Where did you guys go?
Where did you guys... Where the fuck did you guys go?
Oh there you are... Okay... There we go...
That's what you call immersion...
Hahaha...
Alright guys... I... Give me a sec...
I need to grab a lighter...
Real quick... To light this cake up...
So... Give me a sec guys...
I'm gonna grab a lighter...
Um... So I'm gonna disappear...
A little bit...
Hahaha...
And I'm gonna bring dad over too...
I'm gonna bring dad over for us...
Alright...
Dad's here now too guys...
Poof... That's how you do immersion...
Um...
Hahaha...
Don't keep saying that's how you do immersion...
I get un-immersed... No... I need you guys to know...
Uh...
Hahaha... Immersion 101...
Hahaha...
Why are you guys so low?
Because I wanna feel tall...
Um... Anyway...
Anyway...
Let us light up the candle... Wooo...
Wooo...
Alright...
Okay...
Don't tell me your wish but we're gonna blow the candle out together...
Okay... Dragoons...
Uh... We're gonna...
Hahaha...
Yes you guys don't get chairs...
Yes we have like all these chairs behind us...
But you don't have the privilege to sit on a chair...
Hahaha...
Um...
Anyway...
Hahaha...
Anyway guys...
Let's make a wish together...
With dad... Um...
But don't tell me your wish or it's not gonna come true...
Okay guys?
Just remember...
Don't tell me your wish or it's not gonna come true...
Alright?
Alright guys?
Alright... 3...
2...
1...
Wait... It's still on...
Hahaha...
Guys...
You're supposed to help me blow it out...
Okay... We do it again...
3... 2...
1...
Yeah...
Hahaha... Take 2...
Hahaha...
Guys you're supposed to help me blow the candle out...
It's a trick candle...
Oh my gosh...
What do you guys wish for?
Dad... What do you guys wish for?
Hahaha...
We did it!
First try...
First... First try...
Hahaha...
Come on... Come on tell me...
Tell me what you guys wish for...
Hahaha...
You can't tell her it's a trick...
No come on... Tell me...
Who said money?
Alright Aaron...
You're never gonna... Hahaha...
Now you told my wish...
Now you told your wish...
Now you're never getting it...
Hahaha...
Anyway...
Uh...
Thank you everybody...
For coming to my birthday stream...
I...
Hope you guys... I know it's not...
You know... It's not super elaborate...
I didn't do anything like...
Super special for...
Like regarding a project to celebrate...
The birthday... Um...
I just really... I'm just happy to be able to...
Hang out with you guys... Just like... Talk with you guys...
And... Like...
Um... And being able to...
You know... Just hang out...
And just yap your ears off...
And... Um...
Just enjoy the moment... Uh...
Enjoy the moment together...
And I feel like... You know... My last birthday...
We had a very elaborate project...
Going in...
The Skinsuit debut was a very elaborate project going in...
Hahaha...
There was not really a huge gap between me... This...
Birthday and my last birthday...
So...
I think I deserve...
To take it easy for...
This year...
Hahaha...
I think I deserve to take it easy this year...
Um...
But it was a great time... I'm glad to be able to spend...
To celebrate and announce so many fun things...
Um...
We may not have been able to get to the final announcement...
Um... But it is also a dream come true...
And...
That will be...
Revealed...
At a later time...
Um...
It's another goal of mine that was accomplished...
And I'm really happy...
Um...
To reveal it when it's ready...
And I just want to say again...
Thank you everybody...
For coming to the stream...
Um...
For...
The anime expo...
During the panel...
And...
Or like...
You know...
Waking up at 8am to be like...
What was the announcement?
Hahaha...
For those that arrived at 8am...
Waking up at 8am...
Or like staying up really late...
To see what the announcement was...
We're saying thank you guys...
Hahaha...
Um...
And thank you for being there...
And...
Yes...
By the way the biggest hype thing...
Yes!
Hahaha...
Anyway...
Um...
As always everybody...
Stay hydrated...
Posture check...
Get up and move around...
To get that blood flowing...
And if you...
Sit up for me...
Head to bed...
Cause you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everybody...
Bye guys!
Bye!